Do you have any herb or supplement recommendations for brain midingiomas?
So
midingioma is a tumor a
benign tumor in the midinges of the brain so the midinges of your brain are the
Duramata
Mata and the pia Mata that in case your brain and protect your brain and
And those are the what are called the midinges for an anatomical perspective. Now you could get a tumor that's embedded in those midinges.
And that's what's called a midingioma. So a midingioma is a benign tumor that's in the midinges.
It can be anywhere that's encompassing in those midinges that are protecting the brain.
They're not considered deadly, but they can cause a lot of morbidity because as they as any space occupied lesion in the skull, it can compress as it gets larger.
It could compress and
And damage
Durano flow in the cortex and that's what causes problems. So there's other benign brain tumors
Typically fall most common would be what's called a glioma
That are considered benign, but now they're staged differently. They just actually change a staging of those a few years ago to what's called a
braiding system because
The higher the grain the greater chance it has to be coming
a
Cancerous tumor where it is malignant and
Depended on how fast it's growing it
Occupies more space causes more inflammation and causes more damage
And the person's going to have damage and
Compromise depending on where fat tumor is. So midingioma same thing you're going to have more compromise depending on where that tumor is.
What are some herbs or supplements for that?
Well, the biggest thing that you want to be concerned with with a glioma or midingioma is decreasing inflammation.
So
Decreasing inflammation is really the key there's across the board and this really goes for anything
That's going out of the brain is decreasing inflammation because again you have a minimum amount of space and it's taken up
All by your brain. You don't have extra space. You don't have a lot of extra space in your skull
So when you have a tumor growing in there, it's going to impede a brain tissue like I've said.
So decreasing inflammation has got to be your key. So what is the best, what are the best things to do to decrease inflammation?
Well, I could rattle off a lot of supplements but they all fitted to this group called flavonoids or bio flavonoids.
So flavonoid type supplements are your
Your curcumin, your Boswellia, your white willow bark, your green tea extract, your Resveratrol, those are your flavonoids.
Of course, there's a whole bunch of them.
So those are anti-inflammatory nutrients that can help decrease inflammation of the brain.
But doing that alone I think is a mistake. You've got to look at part two is you've got to look at what increases inflammation in the brain.
So what are things that can increase inflammation in the brain? Because you could take a zillion, you know, you could take 10 grams of curcumin, you know, it wouldn't be recommended.
But I would say you could take a ton of these flavonoids and anti-inflammatories.
But if you have some source that's fueling the inflammatory process, it behooves us to try to decrease the source of inflammation.
And you were going to get better results by taking anti-inflammatories. It makes sense, right?
So yes, taking flavonoids is key, but you have to investigate what are some things that are causes of brain inflammation.
So I do have a video if you look up on our log in, and I get a lot of these questions I'm going to point you back to our blog because I've made videos on a lot of this stuff already.
So there's a video I think it's called rate inflammation, or it's neural inflammation.
The talks about brain inflammation and microglio primate, though you could equate the correction of that, the remedy for that to this to gliomas and to meningiomas as well.
So dealing with some causes that increase inflammation around a meningioma, or glioma, or probably microglio cells are going to be the same.
First would be some standard things that this person, person with a meningioma, or any of these things that I discussed, has to cut out immediately would be alcohol.
There's just too many studies that show that that is true.
Now understand, a lot of this data on brain inflammation has surfaced in the last 10 years.
I don't know if you remember a number of years ago, there was these huge lawsuits with the National Football League because there was some retired football players that had major brain issues and
with suicidal events and different things like that that really brought to light issues that happened because of post-concussive syndrome.
So millions of dollars were dumped into the research pool for post-concussive issues in, and what concussions do to the brain which are caused damage to the brain inflammation.
Not unlike what happens with an Alzheimer's patient, not unlike what happens with multiple sclerosis patients, or anybody that has antibodies to neural tissue, as like I mentioned, microglio private.
So watch that video, it's about a half hour video, it goes through that in detail.
But some general things that are always going to cause inflammation of the brain, even when you don't have issues with the brain, you're going to have an increase in inflammation of the brain when you consume alcohol of any kind.
The alcohol does increase inflammation of the brain if you already have insult to the brain via an angiomal or gliomal or like a gliopryamine or antibodies to neural tissue, it's going to make that worse.
And so that's going to be something that the person cuts out of their life.
Secondly is different foods that cause inflammation of the brain.
And just across the, just right off the bat, even if you don't have antibodies to these two food groups, you have to really at least limit them.
And that is gluten and dairy.
It's the, you have gluteumorphine receptors in the gut that fire into the brain, you have caseumorphine receptors in the gut that fire into the brain, those are the proteins of gluten and dairy.
It would be wise to get a test done, which would test for all the peptides of gluten, or gliadin, the gliadin peptides, which are the little parts of the whole protein in itself.
And across the reactants of gliadin and KC.
So getting that test done, that's a Syrex lab, that's the name of the lab.
Syrex array, the rex and array four.
And you can find that in our lab store in the head of our courses.
So understand, you know, if you guys are listening to this and you've not, you've never looked at our website or never looked at our courses,
you're missing out and I'm talking really fast here, I understand.
But go to our blogs, I have a lot of this information in the blogs, like I said, and join one of our, join our course, our autoimmune course, our chronic disease and autoimmune course, probably the best course we got.
Join that course, I go into great detail on all the stuff that we're talking about.
And through the courses, you can order labs at our cost, we don't mark them up one penny, we don't make a penny off of any of our labs.
So, but then you can find out some data and that can be helpful.
So, like I said, you use anti-inflammatory flabby to wait for a midagual back to our question, you would find out what is other causes of inflammation.
And you would treat that, so you get rid of alcohol, you get rid of, you know, at least cut down glue to the dairy, run a test if you have antibodies, if you have any antibodies to any of those, then you have to cut them out completely.
Run a food antibody test for other foods and clean up that, clean up your gut, can greatly decrease the inflammation of your brain.
Testing for pesticides, testing for antibodies to other pathogens, because other pathogens, so you dig down to, if you ever asked your neurologist what causes, but did you almost say, well, it's just tough luck buddy.
But the truth is, is that there's a cause to everything. So, the underlighted cause to a glioma or an angioma, or cancer, or multiple sclerosis, or there are underlighted causes, often they're from pathogens, often they're from chemical toxins.
Just cleaning up the rest of your body can be really, really helpful. And there's other labs that you could run to dig to those causes as well.